fifteen years ago a night of babysitting
turned into one of the scariest nights
of my life and this is that story all
right so this story goes back to
2005-2006 ish it was a Saturday night
and I'm 16 years old so of course you
know I'm livin it up by babysitting I
didn't really go to a lot of parties in
high school so most of my weekends were
just spent getting paid to watch kids
you know his family friends neighbors
neighbors of family friends family
friends of neighbors I was every way I
was cleaning up
I was just raking in the money and I
don't mean to brag but uh I think it's
because I was good at it oh you're good
at babysitting what does that even mean
I will tell you what it means two
reasons one kids have this amazing
ability to not give a [ __ ] about what
anyone thinks about them and for me it's
just so easy to get swept up in that and
then it just becomes legitimately fun
when you let yourself be dumb and silly
and talking racing do all the kids stuff
you forget about then the kids start
having more fun aka they're more likely
to listen to you because you've all
trained at the way they can you know
reason number two which is arguably the
more important reason I always get the
parent tasks done make sure everyone
eats dinner no one has a meltdown
everyone's in bed by 10:00 p.m. whatever
it is basically maintain order I like to
think I've seen it all until this one
specific night which brings us to this
story so like I said it was a cool fall
night I show up at this house at like
6:00 p.m. or something it was actually
my first time babysitting for this
family so I kind of had my work cut out
for me we're talking three kids and a
dog I meet the kids and honestly they
all seemed super chill like a
suspiciously chill like the second that
door closes they're all gonna like turn
their heads at me and attack meet you
age-wise the oldest boy is like eight
nine and there's a girl that's like six
seven and then the littlest boy could
not have been older than four I can
handle that then I meet the dog this
little white poofy dog I have no idea
what breed it is they tell me the dog is
new and they've only had this dog for
three months she's pretty mean the dad
says so prepare yourself for that now
look I love dogs I've grown up with dogs
my entire life but I don't think I've
ever heard a dog introduced as pretty
mean if she
tries to bite you just shake this can of
orders at her okay I get the rest of the
info I'll need for the night they
ordered pizza it'll be there in an hour
everyone can watch TV in bed by 10:00
10:30 they'll be home at midnight
whatever overall this seems pretty by
the books and eventually the parents
leave and the night has begun I'm sure
anyone watching this who has babysat
before is all too familiar with that
awkward moment when the night stops the
kids are definitely thinking who is this
tall weirdo in my house and I'm just
thinking please don't let this night
spiral out of control
but turns out those chill vibes I was
getting were in fact very real chill
vibes the little girl starts coloring at
the kitchen table the two boys ask if I
want to play video games and the dog is
just I don't know what other word to use
besides lurking an hour to goes by the
kids are perfectly nice to me they're
perfectly nice to each other the pizza
comes everyone eats no one makes a mess
then the oldest voice suggests that we
should all watch the Spongebob movie so
of course I'm like I don't want to watch
the Spongebob movie I want to watch the
Spongebob movie twice sorry that scared
anyone watching I can assure you that I
love spongebob very much watch the movie
we all have them I scream I honestly
forget that I'm even babysitting I'm
just having like a delightful evening
and there just so happens to be three
children and a pretty mean dog with me
so its nearing 10:00 10:30 and we're
almost at the point where you have to
have the conversation of it's time to go
to they all voluntarily put themselves
to bed what is happening yeah I know I
don't know and sure enough they all put
on their pajamas brush their teeth head
into their bedrooms and go to sleep
we're independent you're not even
babysitting us at this point I'd feel
bad accepting any money from the parents
like what am I even doing here I don't
know I'll just go downstairs and watch
TV until the parents get home okay now
you're absolutely thinking cool story
nice tale you babysat nice children
please relax so there I'm just sitting
on the couch flipping through channels
texting friends when the little dog
enters the room now if this dog could
talk it absolutely would have said hey
it's a nice night isn't it be a real
shame if someone were to come in
and everything up I try my best to not
make any eye contact as a dog lover I'm
really conflicted I want to pet the dog
but the dog has been introduced as
pretty mean I decided it's not worth the
risk and I just keep my eyes glued to
Iron Chef on the TV but then something
catches my peripheral vision and it's
this goddamn dog it's just laying on its
back at my feet what I'm not supposed to
pet this dog now I look down and it's
just staring back up at me I reach down
immediately flips over tries to bite my
hand and runs away I knew it I knew it
god dammit why do I love dogs so much
lesson learned this dog is in fact
pretty mean oh cool you got bit by a dog
good story no that's not the story you
need to calm down the best part still
coming so I'm still on the couch still
watching Iron Chef this time with a can
of quarters in my hand at this point
it's maybe 11:30 the parents are gonna
be home soon I probably should go
upstairs
turn off any TVs that were left on turn
some lights off you know shut down the
house just nighttime stuff I poked my
head into the oldest boy's room he's
passed out TV's off lights off check I
peek into the girls room she's asleep
lights off check finally I checked the
youngest boy's room the lights are on
and he's not in his bed I have a little
glimmer of panic just relax I'm sure
he's in the other bed that's in the
oldest boy's room so I checked that room
and he isn't there either okay I pick up
the pace and dart over to their parents
room and he's not in there Oh God at
this point my heart is really starting
to pound please don't yell at me for
this next part you know what I do I go
back downstairs and watch TV I know I
know but in my head I'm thinking he's
got to be somewhere in this house
everything's fine I sit there for
probably two minutes
I should find this kid so again I head
upstairs I felt like I was going crazy
I'm flipping all the lights on just to
make sure I wasn't missing something we
were playing video games in the basement
maybe he went to sleep down there I
wasn't gonna rule anything out at this
point he's not in the basement I go back
to the couch my brain is spiraling what
am I supposed to do call the parents and
be like I don't want to freak them out
do I call my parents and ask them to
come help me oh no no that doesn't make
any sense either calling anyone would
have involved telling them what is going
on and it was too scary I couldn't do it
where is this little boy now I'm
checking under beds in closets in
bathrooms literally everywhere and
obviously those things don't make sense
but he wasn't anywhere and the outside
lights on the check the backyard making
sure a child wasn't squeezing in a
midnight jungle gym session I was so
paralyzed with fear so unsure of what
was going on that and I'm not joking
when I say this I debated waiting for
the parents to get home and just acting
like everything was fine
oh right the payment I'm actually gonna
give you a 30% discount because I know
we started with three kids and we've
only got two now so uh I know that's bad
I obviously rule that out but I needed
to figure something out because this was
getting terrifying I turn on every light
I can find I'm looking behind couches
under tables at a certain point it was
time to call their parents was he taken
from his room without me knowing there's
no way someone could have gotten into
the house but that was becoming the only
explanation I'm pacing around and I just
feel sick to my stomach
I walked by the dining room the dog is
laying there on her back staring at me
not a good time my phone is in my hand
this is the worst thing that could have
happened this little boy is gone how did
everything go so well and just 182 this
I wonder into the parents bedroom just
dumbfounded and I sit down on their bed
this is bigger than me messing up
someone could be in danger and I need to
grow up right now suddenly there's
movement under the covers it scares the
absolute dead of me and I whipped the
comforter back there he is sound asleep
under the thickest blanket I have ever
seen every time I had looked in the
parents bedroom
Ben looked completely undisturbed and
when you cover a toddler with a giant
blanket to the naked eye it looks like
nothing is out of the ordinary I exhale
this sigh of relief that is just
unimaginable and I'm sorry if this story
is is anticlimactic in that sense but
it's the truth
I was a hundred percent convinced this
boy was gone and that I had lost
someone's child and just like that he
was simply sleeping in his parents bed
so I scooped him up and put him back in
his own bed so I head downstairs to the
kitchen sit down and just breathe
there's a small lick on my hand I looked
down and of course he pretty mean dog
has returned once again instinctually I
reached down and before I can remember
to pull away if she Nestle's her head
into my hand it's like she knew that I
was on the verge of a full mental
breakdown the parents eventually get
home I smile tell them everyone was
well-behaved and walk out the front door
as I'm headed down the driveway I
remember that I completely forgot to
collect the money so I turned back
towards the house but I see the little
dog in the window just staring at me
unblinking you know what I don't even
want the $60.00 I just want to go home
and that's exactly what I did
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]